A good way to protect data is to encrypt
this information. This way only you or
people you trust are able to view this
encrypted data. If you're encrypting an
entire drive, then you're performing a
full disk encryption. Sometimes you'll
see this referred to as FDE. And if
you're running Windows, then you would
be using Bit Locker to provide full disk
encryption. This is often referred to as
data at rest because this is encrypting
all of the data that's being stored on
your storage drive. Instead of
encrypting everything in a volume, some
operating systems allow you to encrypt
single files or single folders. This is
often built into the file system that
you're using. So, you may want to look
at the properties of a file to see what
options might be available in your OS.
Another good place to have encryption is
on the USB drives that we carry around
and that we often will lose. If you lose
a USB that has encrypted data, you don't
have to worry about someone getting
their hands on your information. You
only have to worry about replacing that
USB drive. In all of these scenarios,
there was some type of key that was used
to encrypt this information. This key is
often built into the operating system
and it's integrated into your login
process. So, it's usually stored on your
local machine or in a central database
like an active directory database. So,
you might not only want to back up your
data, you might also want to be sure
that you have a backup of your
encryption and decryption keys.
In a previous video, we described the
process of password brute forcing where
someone tries every possible combination
to try to discover what your password
might be. One way that you can make this
process very difficult for an attacker
is to increase the amount of entropy in
a password. This is a measurement of how
unpredictable a password might be. So
you might want to use different
character types. Try using uppercase and
lowercase and try using them in a form
that does not make up any obvious
password or word that you might find in
the dictionary. And you might want to
include numbers or special characters to
increase the entropy of these stored
passwords. These days, strong passwords
tend to be eight characters or more. So,
you might want to think about using a
phrase or series of letters that makes
up a much longer phrase to make that
password much more secure.
Another good best practice is to make
sure that your passwords change on a
regular basis. A password age is the
metric that defines how long it has been
since a password was last updated. Many
organizations will set a password
expiration to occur every 30 days, every
60 days, every 90 days, or some other
interval. After that time frame, you are
required to change your password so that
it's something different than what
you've used in the past. And that's an
important consideration. You don't want
someone using one password for 30 days,
using a different password for the next
30 days, and then going back to the
original password on the 30 days after
that. Most systems will remember your
password history and require to use a
different password every time you
update. And if you're running critical
systems, these passwords might update
even more frequently. You might find
that your password is required to be
different every week, every 15 days, or
some other very short interval.
Sometimes you may find that a device, an
operating system, or an application has
a default username or password
associated with it. And when you first
install that software, you use that
default login to gain access to the
system. From a security perspective, we
want to be sure that we change those
default passwords so that no one can
come by later and use the default
credentials to log in. You might also
find passwords being used during the
bootup process for your computer. These
are BIOS passwords or UEFI passwords.
And there are two different types that
you commonly see. One is a supervisor or
administrator password. This is a
password you assign to the BIOS that
prevents someone else from going into
the BIOS and making configuration
changes. Most users would not see this
password because most users aren't
trying to make changes to the BIOS. The
password that most people will see
during startup is a user password. This
is a password you must put into the
system for it to continue the booting
process. And if you don't put in the
right password, then you're not able to
boot the operating system. And from a
best practices perspective, we always
want to require a password. You should
never have a system that allows you
access without putting in some type of
authentication. And you want to be sure
that it's not a blank password. This
would allow a system to automatically
start, but it also makes that system
completely accessible for anyone with
physical access.
On most computers, after a predefined
time of inactivity, it will
automatically start a screen saver. That
screen saver can be set with a lock to
prevent anyone from gaining access to
that system after the computer has gone
idle. This screen saver password can
commonly be integrated with your login
credentials. So the same username and
password you use to log in is the same
password you use for your screen saver.
This is something that's usually turned
on for all of the computers in your
company. But if you'd also like to
enable this at home, you can go into the
personalization features in Windows,
choose the option for lock screen, and
you can configure all of the settings
that will lock your computer when you're
away from your system. In some
companies, users are required to
manually lock their system anytime they
get up from their computer and start
walking away. But you can also configure
your system to automatically start this
after a certain amount of inactivity.
This is a value that you can also set in
these lock screen configuration options
under the screen timeout value.
Not only do we need to enable these
digital locks in our screen savers, but
we also might want to think about
putting on physical locks, especially
with laptops, tablets, and anything else
that can be easily picked up and moved.
Most of these devices have a connection
for a lock. You can wrap that with a
cable around the table and prevent
somebody from walking by and easily
taking your laptop.
During a normal day, we might access
sensitive information that is displayed
on the screen of our laptop or desktop
computer. This might include someone's
name, address, social security
information, healthcare details, and
anything else that might be considered
personally identifiable information or
PII. I've worked with many IT
professionals and it's remarkable how
many of them will simply type in their
password as you're standing next to them
at their keyboard. Obviously, we want to
be aware when sensitive information is
either being input or output from our
system. And we'll want to be sure that
we shield our hands or shield the screen
so that that sensitive information is
not seen by others. If you're in public,
you might want to consider using privacy
filters. This is where your screen will
look completely black to anyone who's
looking from the side. But if you're
looking at your screen directly, you'll
be able to see everything on that
screen. This even works on a plane where
somebody sitting right next to you is
not able to see the information that's
on your laptop display. If you're in an
office environment, it might be a good
idea to rearrange your desk so that the
monitor is facing you and not facing
outward where other people might be able
to see it. And if you are in public,
keep in mind that the information
displayed on your screen might be seen
by others. So, it might be a good idea
to only show nonsensitive information on
your screen when you're in those types
of environments.
One of the reasons that attackers like
to get their hands on lists of passwords
and email addresses is because many
people will reuse those passwords on all
of the websites that they visit. This
makes it very easy for an attacker to
breach a password on one site and then
use that password on many other sites to
gain access to your accounts. The best
practice would be to use a different
password for different sites. This way,
if an attacker does gain access to a
password on one site, they would not be
able to use that password on any other
site. The problem with this, of course,
is now you have to remember many more
passwords on many other sites. And
instead of writing these down, we might
instead want to put all of these
different passwords into a password
vault. This password manager contains
all of your emails, all of your
passwords, and any other important
information that you use to log in to
multiple websites. This is obviously an
important database, so it's usually
encrypted and protected with a very
strong password. You might find that
this password management feature is
built into the browser that you're using
or it may be part of the operating
system that you're currently using. And
many organizations will have password
managers used for everyone in the
company so that they know that all of
those passwords are secure, encrypted,
and safe from anyone else gaining
access.
Here's a sample screen of a password
manager that shows the different
passwords that have been saved. This
user has 292 saved passwords and you can
see website one, website 2, website 3
and so on. You can see the username that
was used to log in. On most of these,
it's the user's email address and then
there is a separate password that is
stored for each one of these sites.
These password managers can often create
new passwords that are automatically
defined as a certain strength. You can
configure using numbers, letters,
symbols, and you can have that password
automatically associated with a
particular site.
Most organizations recognize that a good
security best practice is to only assign
rights and permissions that are
necessary for someone to do their job.
You would not want to assign
administrator rights to everyone in the
organization. This would effectively
grant everyone access to all data in the
company and it would also make it much
easier for an attacker to take advantage
of the access that you've created.
Instead, most organizations will create
different groups and they'll assign
security rights and permissions to those
groups. To use those groups, you would
assign a user into the group and every
user you assigned into the group would
take the rights and permissions
associated with that group. This makes
it very easy to have the right set of
permissions for the right set of tasks
and it also makes it very easy to scale
as more and more people join the
organization. Some companies will set
login restrictions based on the time of
day. So if someone's trying to log in
during the hours of 8 and 6, the system
will allow that. But if someone tries to
log in at 3:00 in the morning, your
system may not allow that because a
login restriction has been previously
configured.
Many operating systems will include a
set of default accounts. Some of these
accounts are used for system purposes
and other accounts are used for
individuals to be able to log in. But
not all of these accounts are necessary
to run. And in fact, many of these
accounts should be turned off by
default. For example, you might want to
disable the guest account on your system
because it might be very unusual for a
guest to log into your computer. And if
some of these accounts are system
accounts, you might want to disable the
capability for that account to log in
interactively. This means no one would
be able to sit at your desk, type in the
username and password of a system
account, and be able to then gain access
to your desktop and your file system.
And if you've ever installed a new
firewall, a new switch, or new router,
you may have noticed that the default
user login is probably admin with a
password of admin. This is obviously a
set of default credentials that need to
be changed as soon as possible to
prevent someone else from gaining access
to that system.
If someone wanted to find your password
using a brute force attack, they could
try an online attack where they're
presented with a login screen. They
would type in your username and then try
a password. And when that one didn't
work, they would try logging in again
with your username and a different
password. If that one doesn't work, they
try again with your username and a third
password. and they keep trying this
process until hopefully they're able to
brute force your account. In most
operating systems, we're able to stop
this type of online brute force attack
by setting thresholds for failed
passwords. If someone tries to log in
more than five times with the wrong
password, we can institute a series of
lockdowns that would prevent any other
attempts. For example, Windows has a
security policy that has a machine
account lockout threshold. And if you
were to look at the details of this,
after a certain number of failed login
attempts, the system reboots and when it
reboots, you have to provide the Bit
Locker credentials to gain access to
that computer again. We might also want
to be sure that we're using some of
these policies to automatically lock the
system after inactivity or if it's able
to tell that you've walked away, it
might be able to lock the system
automatically. And when you're initially
creating an account in your system, you
might want to set an expiration date,
especially if this account will be used
by a temporary worker or contractor
who's only going to be using it for 30
days.
On very old versions of Windows, this
would be versions in Windows Vista and
earlier, there was a feature known as
AutoRun. Auto run worked by looking for
special files that may have been added
to media on a removable drive. So if you
plugged in a USB drive, it looked for an
autorun file and began running
executable files from that USB drive.
This is obviously something that we
would not want to happen in today's
security environments. And so auto run
has not been part of Windows since
Windows Vista. One feature that still is
in Windows is autoplay. This is in the
settings app under Bluetooth and
devices. You'll see an option for
autoplay. Unlike auto run that focused
on running executables, autoplay focuses
on running media. So this might be
movies, music or images. That's
certainly a much lower security risk,
but you might still want to enable or
disable that feature. You can find it
under settings, Bluetooth and devices,
and autoplay. Under the autoplay
options, you can choose to take no
action when that media is connected. You
can open the folder to view the files
using File Explorer, or you can have the
system ask you every time you plug in
that media.
You're probably very familiar with the
applications you use on your Windows
desktop, but there's also a number of
applications that are running behind the
scenes that you never see. These are
Windows services and they are important
tasks that keep our operating system
running. Sometimes these services are
installed with other applications to
provide support services for that
particular app. The challenge, of
course, is that any executable running
on your system is a potential security
threat. And these executables that are
running as services are just as much a
threat as applications that are running
on your desktop. If you remove the
service, you've removed the threat. So,
as a best practice, you might want to
look at the services running on your
system, and if you see any that you're
not using, you might want to disable
those.